.
Thank you.
Try it again with the mic on.
It being 930, I'm going to call the subcommittee work session for Senate Bill 282 to order.
And would you like to, Representative Marsh?
Yes, I would move that we recommend to the full committee adoption of Amendment 1596H.
I second.
Okay.
And any discussion?
The discussion is this accomplishes what we decided on Friday, and there are really no changes in it.
And we've heard from...
Go.
I'm not too worried about it.
and we've heard from those who worked with us on the amendment that it is acceptable.
Okay.
I guess I'll call the roll for this.
So this is for the adoption of Amendment 2022-1596-H to Senate Bill 282.
Representative Marsh?
Yes.
Representative Grota?
And the chair votes yes.
Okay.
So that's three to zero.
And anybody want to make another motion?
I move that Senate bill 282 ought to pass with amendment 1596 H and we've discussed it sufficiently.
I'll second that one.
Do you want to speak to your motion?
I think we've discussed it sufficiently.
Okay.
In that case, I'll call the roll.
Representative Marsh?
Yes.
Representative Grota?
And the chair votes yes.
That's 3-2.
And the motion passes.
So I'm going to, unless there's anything else, I'll close the subcommittee work session on Senate Bill 282 Thank you.
Thank you.
.